I just moved here from Canada I hate it
like the other day I held the door open
for somebody for 20 minutes it was for
one person at first but then other
people just kept walking through I was
like oh this is my job now
I like being Canadian America it's cool
it's just like being in a really easy
escape room like I have all the clues I
can leave at any time
just see if you guys figure this out or
not if you don't know what an escape
room is that's when you have so much
privilege you pay somebody to take it
away like oh this is just a fun
afternoon for me I'll never do it again
I've had to I've had some tough
situations in my life like I didn't have
Wi-Fi for a month 30 days no Wi-Fi it
was the first time I didn't have Wi-Fi
since Wi-Fi so I changed a lot I'm
different now
I did crazy stuff without Wi-Fi did
crazy stuff like I bought a puzzle
that's insane to buy a but like nobody
buys i+ like puzzles just show up like
puzzles are just there but I wouldn't
bought one the guy's like are you sure I
was like yeah I don't know what to do
without the internet I like it is a cool
puzzle it's got animals on it eating
like cheesy pizza it's a good puzzle
animals don't eat that they don't have
the infrastructure
it was a thousand pieces took me five
hours two hundred pieces an hour it's
really good I have a high puzzle average
I don't know what you're working with
puzzle average wise but one-on-one me at
puzzles destroy you if you're having
trouble with a puzzle hit me up you know
I'm online I'll be over there I'll
finish it in two to three hours if
you've got the corners done thirty
minutes tops
I'll just close in on that puzzle to be
like wow this kid is autistic and I'm
definitely on the spectrum for sure my
dad told me that he's not a doctor I
don't know finally probably puzzles I
don't know what to do with them when
you're done with them like I don't want
to break it up put it back in the box
like I'm never gonna do a puzzle again
like my roommate was just gonna come
home and I'd be like I'll check out her
new dorm at like it breaks please don't
step on it it took forever but I didn't
have Wi-Fi or data at the time because I
live like a pirate so I had to go to the
local library to Google what to do with
the puzzle when you're done with it
yeah and I like to use the resources
available to me in my municipality I pay
taxes I think I pay taxes I'm probably
gonna get audited I found this product
on Amazon is called puzzle glue yeah
it's a pretty straightforward product
you guys don't get it from its name what
you do is you use the puzzle glue okay
and then you glue the puzzle and then
you frame it and you put it on your wall
and it's a popular product you know a
lot of people are using it they have 4.5
stars 44 reviews 44 44 44 different
people
44 separate individuals were all alone
and at the same time thought I have to
review this I read every review I did
for all 44 my favorite review was out of
all the puzzle glue I've tried puzzle
glue is by far the best
I bought puzzle glue i frame four
puzzles and then I moved in with my
girlfriend and she's like you're not
putting these on my wall I was like you
don't know art you don't get it
these are Gavin originals that's my name
because you guys probably forgot I don't
we broke up though me and that girl
I think the puzzles were part of it
honestly we lived together for a year
because that's how long the lease was
people were like why'd you break up and
I was like I didn't like the sound of
her chewing I told her that once and
she's like well if I don't chew I'll
choke I'll be like oh that's actually
would work out for me
no there's only a couple ways to get out
of the lease I read it I'm good at
puzzles I figured it out living with
someone I learned is just like a lot of
eye contact like that's all it is it's
just like more like before didn't live
together not that much eye contact and
then we live together there's like 120 %
more eye contact like we lived in a
one-bedroom apartment not a lot of
corners in the apartment but around
every corner is just like more eye
contact it's like a you a cat like stop
peeking at me like we made eye contact
during sex
and I was like I never have to have this
again like I'm like we made eye contact
during set and then I just said I just
said what
just like I dropped all my books but it
was way different because I was inside
of her so it's a terrible analogy